le débat continue en direct dans la voie
est libre avec vous Lilian meelet oui
suite de la voie est libre Arnaud
consacré au mariage pour tous à ses
conséquences dans la société dans la vie
politique française avec Françoise vergu
Peltier conseillère d'ivvergauche
conseillère général d'ivgauche de
sonéloir Mathieu Morau de l'association
Sigal Dijon Damien thleux secrétaire
départemental adjoint de l'UMP et
Patrick goubau de la manif pour tous en
SA et Loire on a
terminé la tranche précédente on parlait
de la GPA vous avz de la gestation Pouru
vous aviez envie de compléter
oui sur sur sur cette question vous nous
dites que le débat est pas tranché et
vous nous faites souvent des retours un
petit peu historiques puis j'aimerais en
allant un petit peu moins loin que que
le début du siècle dernier revenir sur
ce que disait madame isabette Guigou en
98 qui je cite nous disait il n'est pas
question ni aujourd'hui ni demain que
deux personnes physiques du même sexe
quel que soit leur sexe puisse se marier
et le gouvernement dont je fais partie
ne proposera jamais l'adoption ni la
procréation médicalement assisté pour
les concubins homosexuels en 2013
lorsqu'elle sera lie au mariage pour
tous elle nous déclare à l'époque
l'important était de faire passer le pax
il n'était pas possible de mettre sur la
table la question du mariage homosexuel
même au sein du gouvernement il a fallu
que j'insiste la fin justifier les
moyens donc vous savez ce débat
aujourd'hui effectivement sur la GPA sur
la PMA il est pas tranché vous nous
dites que ce n'est pas une revendication
des associations de défense tel que
Sigal vous ne donnez même pas votre
propre position à titre personnel euh je
voudrais aussi avancer sur la la
circulaire tobira qui est sur justement
cette question de de la PMA et et de la
GPA une espèce de crisie totale
c'est-à-dire que quelque chose qui est
interdit en France que l'on peut
condamner ou pas même si le débat n'est
pas terminé puisque vous le dites
vous-même et que ça sera à mon avis
votre prochaine revendication vous
inciter à aller le faire à l'étranger et
puis à revenir en France et à le
légaliser d'une certaine façon un peu
comme si on autorisait un ministre à
avoir des comptes en Suisse et puis une
fois qu'il revient on le dédoine
complètement pour l'instant c'est les
tribunaux
quiver on d'accord deation c'est bienè
sur la loiira pour le faire
on on une des idées qu'on avait avec
dans cette émission c'était aussi de
parler au moment où allez on est à une
semaine d'ailleurs des l'élection du
président de
l'UMP de parler aussi de la montée dans
la vie politique française d'un
mouvement qui n'existait pas avant je me
tourne vers vous Patrick goubau c'est la
manif pour
tous vous avez à nouveau manifesté en
octobre dernier donc une fois que la loi
était votée on a donc compris que vous
n'étiez pas un objet destiné à empêcher
uniquement la loi sur le mariage pour
tous mais que vous aviez une vue plus
longue vous êtes un nouveau parti
politique ah pas du tout la manif pour
tous c'est un mouvement très spontané de
personnes très responsables qui son dit
les politiques font n'importe quoi et il
est temps que les familles se lèvent
pour remettre un petit peu l'église au
milieu du village et les choses à
l'endroit l'église au milieu du village
ça c'est bien ça dont il est question
vous avez vous avez d'ailleurs vous avez
d'ailleurs présenté la tout à l'heure ça
c'est assez étonnant vous avez présenté
la la question du mariage comme étant
une entité religieuse comme
étant une chose religieuse ça n'a rien à
voir le mariage humain existe bien
depuis bien plus longtemps et le fait
que qu'un mariage entre deux personnes
de sexe différentes engendre des enfants
et qui se s'unissent et mettent en place
un une une une relation et les
permettant de les élever dans les
meilleures conditions possibles ça ça ne
vient pas de l'Église c'est quelque
chose qui est aussi vieux que l'humanité
en ça c'est une parenthèse donc la
manive pour tous pour répondre à votre
question est effectivement un mouvement
spontané deux familles qui se sont dit
c'est plus possible de laisser euh faire
n'importe quoi il faut aujourd'hui qu'on
se prenne en main donc c'est
majoritairement très majoritairement des
gens qui n'ont jamais fait de politique
et qui pour la plupart n'en font jamais
et qui se sont dit il est temps de se
lever je je vous coupe parce que vous
êtes originaire de sonéoir oui et un
certain nombre de d'observateurs
estiment que la manif pour tous elle est
pas spontanée du tout et qu'elle a été
largement organisée en particulier
autour de la Communauté de l'Emmanuel
Apparel Monial qui a même eu une réunion
à la tousin 2012 qui a organisé et mis
en place la manif pour tous est-ce que
c'est vrai tout
si c'était vrai enfin moi j'en suis pas
je suis pas du tout au courant de ça non
non c'était très spontané et puis de
toute façon si la sonéoire avait été
capable d'entraîner le reste de la
France ça c'est aussi c'est faire
beaucoup d'honneur à notre département
non je pense que effectivement il y a eu
de très très
nombreuses prise de conscience partout
en France dans des milieux très divers
vous savez par exemple j'étais à Lyon
effectivement au au mois d'octobre moi
j'ai côtoyé pendant toute la
manifestation des musulmans bon je pense
pas que ce soit la Communauté de
l'Emmanuel de Parel Monial qui est qui
est qui est motivé des musulmans à venir
manifester donc je crois que ça lui
faire beaucoup d'honneur mais c'est
c'est ça n'est pas le cas non non c'est
un mouvement très spontané de gens qui
se sont dit on est en train de faire
n'importe quoi on est en train de
toucher aux fondamentaux de la société
de casser la société française de la
fragmenter et il est temps que les
familles se lèvent parce que les
politiques ne font plus le boulot ça
c'est l'origine de la manif pour tous
ensuite il est clair que une fois que la
loi a été votée qu'est-ce qu'on s'est
dit vous rappelez ce slogan de la manif
forsous c'est on ne lâche rien c'est pas
je peux vous dire que c'est toujours
vrai c'est celui des supportes de la
gocerge ah bah écoutez très bien on ne
lâche rien et on ne lâchera rien
pourquoi parce qu'on touche à quelque
chose de fondamental auprès duquel les
les hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques devraient devraira sapprocher
avec beaucoup de respect beaucoup de
délicatesse on touche à la famille on
touche à l'enfant tout à l'heure on a
parlé de droit on a oublié un tout petit
détail c'est le droit de l'enfant de
connaître son papa et sa maman tous les
tous les T de connaître de connaître de
con vous dites le droit d'un enfant à
avoir un papa et une maman ça c'est un
droit que vous avez inventé je suis Rav
je suis ravi de vous entendre corriger
votre propre propos parce que
efftivement nous dans No
famillesarentales il est pas question de
dire à par exemple dans le cadre d'un
couple de femme de dire tu n'as pas de
papa il est jamais il a jamais été
question de le faire et ça c'est ce que
vous avez raconté depuis le début
c'estàd que quand vous dites que votre
mouvement est spontané peut-être mais il
est surtout fondé sur un mensonge un
mensonge que vous avez répéter à
longueur de plateau télé et à longueur
d'interview journalistique sûrement avec
beaucoup trop de de Zè de la part des
médias mais pour nous dire qu'en fait on
allit inscrire sur l'état civil des
enfants qu'il y avait effectivement que
deux papas ou deux mamans et absolument
pas de d'origine
biologique voilà c'est c'est assez c'est
assez par on connaissait pas encore 10
minutes et vous me traitez déjà de
menteur mais c'est pas vousent plate pas
vous traite de menteur c'est c'est votre
mouvement qui est basé sur un mensonge
il y a rien personnel
làdedans vou voulaz répondre et moi j'ai
envie de vous aider à répondre en vous
demandant si c'est pas aussi parce que
la montée la manie pour tous conincide
exactement avec les grosses difficultés
de l'UMP est-ce que c'est pas en terme
calendaire Patrick goubau aussi est-ce
que c'est pas c'est aussi ces
difficultés de votre parti qui ont qui a
eu du mal à être audible sur ces sujetsl
qui font que la manif pour tous elle a
pris la place politiquement parce que
même si vous dites que vous êtes pas un
parti politique elle a pris dans le
débat politique la place de l'UMP à ce
moment-là euh non parce que notre
position à l'UMP a toujours été claire
malgré quelques voix dissonantes moi ce
que ce que j'aimerais aussi un petit peu
rappeler parce que plusieurs fois c'est
sous-entendu dans dans les positions que
vous donnez par rapport à à ce que l'on
peut défendre c'est une espèce de
d'homophobie l'attente que parce que
nous ne serions pas d'accord avec vous
nous serions homophobes je tiens à
rappeler quand même que la dernière
grande loi qui condamnait les propos
homophobes et discriminant a été fait
par la droite sous le gouvernement
rafarin en 2004 donc n pouvez pas taxer
tout le monde d'homophobie dès qu'on
vous n'estes pas d'accord avec vous un
premier point dis simplement que on voit
bien à travers du discours de Monsieur
que imaginez des familles m parentales
qui puissent se Mar avoir des enfants ça
dérange
encoreéral ça dérange pour les enfants
je vais terminer mon propos le deuxème
point qu'il y a eu c'est que on a eu un
un président de la républque qui nous
vouleit une France apaisée c'était ses
ses propres termes je pense que
effectivement il y a eu des propos
homophobes qui ont été dans le cadre de
ce débats qui ont été ABS qui n qui
doivent être condamnés avec la plus
grande force d'une certaine minorité
vraiment extrêmement minoritaire de
certaines personnes au sein de l'UMP dès
que ça a été le cas ça a été sanctionné
immédiatement par contre nous avons
effectivement un mouvement qui est la
manif pour tous qui n'est pas composé
que de couples hétérosexuel catholiqu il
y a de toute religion de toute obédience
il y avait des gens qui nétaient nétait
pas engagé sur le plan religieux qui
n'était pas à droite vous avez des gens
de gauche vous avez des gens qui
viennent de partout et ces gens-là ont
été sur le plan de leurs valeurs sur le
plan de ce qu'ils exprimaient ont été un
peu maltraités par le gouvernement sur
la façon dont ils ont été pu être
accueillis dans la rue avec une certaine
fermeté j'aurais aimé que la même
fermeté soit sur la dernière
manifestation en hommage si on Puut dire
en hommage à remémy frais dans le
centrville de Dijon voilà il y a eu une
façon de faire de traiter ces
personneslà qui a été à mon avis pas
intelligente dans la gestion de ce débat
François vergu monsieur goubau disait
tout à l'heure parla de M 68 à cité m 68
probablement avec humour parce que en
préparant cette émission on avait parlé
de du livre du politologue Gael bruier
qui qui a analysé la manif pour tous en
la qualifiant de mes 68 conservateurs
euh est-ce que est-ce que c'est un
nouveau M68 à l'envers la manif pour
tous je trouve un peu insultant de de
comparer ce mouvement conservateur qui
revient en balancier après un grand
mouvement allant vers l'égalité des
droits né dans les années 70 où les
femmes je vous rappelle il y avait un
chef de famille n'avait pas le droit
d'ouvrir un compte bancaire n'avait pas
le droit de disposer de leur salaire
n'avait pas le droit de souscrire un
contrat donc je trouve que on on est là
et monsieur l'a exprimé d'une façon mais
magistrale par l'église au milieu du
village et il est là le problème c'est
que on a un mouvement de laïcisation de
la société depuis de siècles avec des
grandes lois de liberté et puis il y a
ce ce contreemouvement de de de de de de
de conservateurs qui veulent nous faire
revenir à à des droits naturels mais de
quelle nature parl parle-t-on la droit
la loi du plus fort euh François
Hollande il voulait une France apaisée
certes mais il voulait surtout une
France de l'égalité et si cette loi
appte pas l'égalité et elle est une loi
liberté et bien c'est l'essence même et
on se disait tous les deux tout à
l'heure que c'est probablement un des
engagements qui est finalement ne fait
plus débat parmi les Français de tiers
en sont parfaitement satisfaits il
voudrait qu'on pass à autre chose
effectivement aujourd'hui ils sont plus
inquiets sur les questions de l'emploi
sur les questions d'économie oui on cela
on peut le
partager Patrick goubau un mot sur il
nous reste une minute 30 très peu de
temps mais il y a des élections qui qui
arrivent est-ce que la vocation de la
manif pour tous ça va être de peser dans
les choix politiques qui vont être fait
et on va dire est-ce que vous voulez
prendre partie à l'élection ou est-ce
que vous vous allez irriguer vous
souhaitez irriguer l'ensemble des des
partis politiques plutôt à droite on va
dire parce que pour l'instant on peut
pas dire que la gauche vous accueille à
bras ouvert alors je vais répondre à
votre question simplement je suis un
petit peu engêné qu'on ait pas parlé de
la la GPA on en a très peu parlé donc je
recommande un livre d'une dame qui n'est
pas franchement de droite qui s'appelle
sivian agasanski qui est l'épouse de J
Jospin qui s'appelle le cor miette qui
démontre la barbarie de la GPA et à quel
point ça va rendre ça va mettre les
femmes en esclavage je juste faire cette
juste on on n'est pas de gauche parce
qu'on est marié avec quelqu'un de gauche
hein
madame magazanski n'est probablement pas
de gauche parce que je socialist donc
vous pensez qu'elle est de droite très
bien enfin je vous recommande cette
lecture
le en tout cas en tout cas très vite en
20 secondes par 20 secondes la manif
pour tous il y a des gens qui vont faire
de la politique donc ils ne voudront pas
en faire ceux qui veulent faire la
politique ça s'appelle sens commun et
effectivement sens commun sa mission la
mission qui s'est donnée c'est de
travailler au sein de l'UMP pour
remettre ces idées là au centre du débat
et ce qui est bien c'est que la semaine
dernière elles ont été mises au centre
du débat vous refermez l'émission
comment va commencé puisque c'est
effectivement devant les militants de
sens commun que Nicolas Sarkozi avait
évoqué l'abrogation merci à tous les
quatre d'être venus débattre on se
demandait est-ce que ce sera long ou pas
long on avait besoin de tout ce temps
pour en débattre merci à tous les quatre
bon weekend au
revoir